[Music]
[Applause]
what's up folks I'm Walter Brennan yak
and this is awesome comics your one-stop
shop for everything
comic quick entertainment and we're
going a little manga related little
anime related we are talking about the
legacy of Dragon Ball Z with some very
special guests before I get to them we
want to always employ it like our
Facebook page it's facebook.com slash
your awesome comic show and we have
exclusive videos that go up there every
single Thursday sometimes more than once
a week
go ahead and give us a like on there
okay I will go to my right first you
search she's a regular on the show she's
a good friend of mine she's had the
roost what's up oh nothing much you know
I'm excited I like when we were able to
delve into the world of anime that's I
love anime so I'm excited about this
your power level is you know it's over
9000 and our special guest today you saw
him on our favorite anime episodes mr.
Malcolm ray yeah this is Malcolm ray
I love anime and actually it's 8000
[Music]
we're surrounded by all these things
this is weird this is a comfortable
place okay so we're gonna talk about a
few things about Dragon Ball Z and sort
of the impact that I had on us and on
American culture especially I think oh
so let's let's get into it so Dragon
Ball Z is probably like the most
American accepted anime I think a lot of
people don't even watch anime myself
included I'm not a big anime guy and I
love Dragon Ball Z so why do you think
that is why do you think Dragon Ball
resonates with Americans specifically is
because of all the action and crazy
stuff that happens in it we think
Malcolm I think it is like a combination
of just that action and the the lore of
the hero's journey
it's the hero's journey it's like in its
basic form as the hero's journey you
know you have you know the young man
that's you know seeking to become the
greatest most powerful fighter and like
it originally started with Dragon Ball
right and you know Goku is just a little
kid and forest and you know he runs into
the the unwilling here Obama who had
being hyper genius is searching for
Dragon Balls and they end up going on
during together to claim a request yeah
merry quest and it's just so much fun I
mean there's comedy there's action and
just hijinks and enemies that become
friends and it's it's just a perfect
combination of rice stuff you got
punching and you've got jokes being
cracked it's so now it was Marvel's
Marvel's Cinematic Universe before the
action like you said action and comedy
and it really resonated not just with I
know you guys specifically about the
American audience and but it was a huge
beauty right oh no like it changed some
of the face of the 80's and 90's anime
it was simple animation with a great
story and so it really changed how
people approach some anime mmm the
Creator yeah yeah so I think it cuz it
spans such a long period of time too I
mean from Dragonball like you said you
get to see Goku as a kid and what became
popular in America's Dragonball Z right
yeah I mean that's the main focus of
everything that's what the movies now
are Dragon Ball Z movies very
specifically so but we get to see over
years of time we get to see his son grow
up we can see Gohan grow up we get to
see characters age and die and come back
and so let's get into a couple these
topic things here I wrote out so where
did you see Dragon Ball Z first or
Dragon Ball whatever were you introduced
to it first either
I actually was introduced to it on
Cartoon Network you know that's where a
lot of people are I think most people so
right I used to watch tsunami and I was
fairly like I said into anime so I was
watching my shirt of Sailor Moon
I was watching Sailor Moon and other
like I actually was super reluctant to
give it a try at first really because I
was very set in my ways of I like
magical girl shows and I like
mecca's and this is neither of those
things not like it but that my friends
kept daddy you liked it you all liked it
we promise it's it's got a lot of drama
a lot of comedy
you'll like it we promise so then I went
back and watched some other ones that my
friends had videotapes of cartoon I did
that all the time liking it a lot yeah I
broke out of my shell of my two things
that I liked I mean yeah most people saw
it on Cartoon Network first where did
you see it first I saw it on Fox Fox
Kids like it blew my mind because I was
just getting introduced to anime cuz
like shows that I watched before it was
like you know x-men was out you know
spider-man yeah like and then just like
random other cartoon shows but then you
know I would go into like comic book
stores I'd see like this you know this
funky-looking
like design characters and it's like oh
yeah that's anime and I'm like anime
yeah cartoons from Japan yes I started
watching it and it just like blew my lid
completely off I'm like holy crap it's
like these guys are like flying across
the screen or punch each other through
mountains and all this other crazy
I'm like this is insane it changed my
world it made me this was my
introduction to anime so it it was like
my go-to and then like a year later
after I discovered it I saw it appear on
Cartoon Network right and that's when I
became addicted that's when I started
videotaping it because you know
yeah because like it would start airing
as I got out of school so I would have
to videotape it to make sure that I
caught that episode before the week's
new episode which was to on tsunami yeah
yeah I think I saw it it was like
Saturday mornings or something where I
would see at first something like that
but I think it was a fox or something
but I definitely saw it before it was on
Cartoon Network it was the the ocean Ted
were talking about oh yeah yeah oh
yeah it was a different it was much
different it was when Napa said he was
gonna kill somebody he was like I'm
gonna send you a text imagine
very direct sensory ocean de of their
Canadian there are Canadian focus so it
kind of makes sense that they're a
little more you know it was interesting
going back then and watching it unedited
oh yeah oh this is super intense there
is blood involved it's very busy can get
pretty dark yeah we're sure yeah
absolutely
we're getting their limbs knocked off it
freezes just a floating yeah yeah so
like I saw it on there first but then I
obviously watched on Toonami and Cartoon
Network and yeah that was another thing
right home from school was Marshall
Goering lousy and sometimes they play
episodes back-to-back I think a couple
blocks were like that for a while yeah
so I would you know I was a problem with
homework was not wanting to do homework
cuz I would needed to see during Rosie
when they would they would go through
like a whole like half a saga or
something and then they would start from
the beginning like on the next clipping
and we wouldn't see the the new episode
for months it was a ridiculous way of
presenting a television show yeah it was
quite easy yeah yeah I think it was
actually a couple of years like ocean
only dubbed up until the ginyu bark yeah
then Funimation took over and then they
had to go back and read of it from the
same side so it was actually four years
where it was like Funimation like dubbed
everything from like the second half of
the ginyu arc onwards and if you wanted
to watch the same side you have to go
back to the ocean dub right yeah it was
just like that for years but then
obscene Funimation got all the rights
and they removed up everything and now
we got Sean Shamu Goku right yeah yeah I
love the show still watch it it's still
great would watch I mean since the the
Buu saga was not gonna come out
I'm Cartoon Network for like
months or something yeah so they
released these the video cassette tapes
the VHS only my cousin bought a bunch of
those so that's how I watched the Buu
saga was through those tapes because it
took so freakin long to come on Cartoon
Network I was like I cannot wait for
this give me give me the tapes so my
cousin has like my cousin Nick has like
this whole you know on the back it
performs an image yeah yeah I remember
those days classic stuff
so I want to talk about some of our
favorite characters from this Malcolm
who is your favorite character or some
of your favorite characters from Dragon
Ball Z my favorite character right off
the bat like when I first saw Dragon
Ball Z it was yeah it was like in the
middle of the making an arc that's where
I was introduced and you know it was a
little confusing like I'm like watching
this and my favorite character like
graph the bat was Gohan it was like yeah
when he was like dressed up in the
little namekian garb and he had his
little bowl cut yeah like you know he's
just this little kid but he's kicking so
much and like an that rage thing going
on back then yeah yeah he hit like
full-on rage like he would get pissed
off and suddenly his power level would
like skyrocket beyond anyone's
expectations and yeah and you know like
that resonated with me because I was a
little kid at the time I hadn't been
like like six seven yeah yeah I was like
man I wouldn't like it actually inspired
me to get into martial arts like yeah I
started like taking large-scale is I
wouldn't be like Gohan I wasn't the kid
that can just like kick anyone's ass you
know if someone's a great yeah he's like
you know just a kid you know he you just
try just to study he tries to you know
do right by his parents right but then
he's got like the weight of the world on
his shoulders when he has like seeing
his friends and he has a he he goes over
I think probably the biggest change over
the the whole series because he starts
off as a in the same side he's like four
or something yeah he's super young and
by the end of DBZ he's a full grown man
he's like 20 or something yeah something
like that and of the Buu saga so yeah so
yeah he goes through a full I mean we
could see him grow up you know right and
we get to see him change and sometimes
for the better sometimes not for the
best I thought Gohan should have started
taken on the mantle of Goku which they
tried to yeah that's what they deeply
rejected so much yeah people rejected it
fans were like no we want our Goku yeah
to be the hero
Goku but I mean go on it was such a
perfect setup and then I'll just end in
a bookworm yeah you know they completely
undid it
it's terrible terrible okay I know who
is your favorite character um I was
always into more of the villain slash
antihero so like Vegeta is my favorite I
love Vegeta I just like yeah he always
had interesting new things going on like
Vegeta Goku was very like he does what's
right and I was I was bored by that I
liked that Vegeta was a complex
character villain but also kind of a
hero
I also later on was a big fan of trunks
how could you not be especially do you
guys see history trunks yes history
maybe the best movie maybe close yes the
best storyline yeah yeah so you get to
see his backstory in that movie
impossible it's amazing any Super Saiyan
the first time you clapped so hard that
his blood comes out of his hand yeah
yeah great stuff being Super Saiyan was
kind of a huge yeah so yeah so trunks is
a great character Vegeta a great
character oh I mean and they both had VG
especially was up and down right like
more antihero yeah my favorite character
was always piccolo I Oh piccolo from the
very beginning I loved piccolo and he
also goes through that bad guy at the
beginning and he I guess he was sort of
anti here at first but he becomes like
the straight-laced like always reliable
good guy thanks throughout most of this
series and him training his relationship
with go on is like the second favorite
character yeah that's amazing and I love
how they pair you that and Dragon Ball
dad so much so yeah they're they're back
and forth is always great and then him
with comi and he just had such a such an
aura of like destiny around him I think
like the entire time is like good cuz he
started off as such a bad guy
you know the the egg son of King Piccolo
and all that oh yeah
that you know seeing him grow and you
could tell he was just meant for my work
but yeah that you know he was just a
really cool character I always loved
piccolo and I always just loved him
standing in the background and you know
when he in in the Android saga when he
when he fused with Cammy and was the
most powerful character in the DV
universe for like a little while I was
[Music]
oh left him in Hell like one of the best
heroes of the show and you leave in Hell
just really briefly real quick I don't
like Jane Ball GT I wanted to like it
was so excited about it you know when
watching DBZ and then seeing like you
know little pictures and stuff cool yeah
yeah watch it yeah and then it turned
out to be I think it's garbage from the
theme song through everything it's all
the music in Z Bruce bath liners
American scoreline I want to talk about
is one of the best like scores of a TV
show I think ever I loved that score
yeah the score is fantastic all the
different themes you know the different
things uh my favorite themes are
honestly like between Vegeta and trunks
right because yeah the piano the trunks
yet the bells the ultra Super Saiyan
episode was great yeah powering up too
much but
it happens right Super Saiyan 3 Goku
theme oh yeah that one
holy yeah oh just so many like great
great themes yeah awful Bruce Falcon and
to sell how can I talk about the self a
boy yeah yeah I know there's a lot of
defenders of the Japanese score and it's
very it's very hokey it's you know you
know it's orchestral it's and it comes
from a specific time yeah definitely
it's located yeah it's a little dated
but I mean it's okay you know it's
nostalgic to look back on it and you
know appreciate the music cuz like
speaking of Dragon Ball Z's legacy
they've influenced like shown in our
since its inception like right but that
orchestral sound you can hear it in like
one piece mm-hmm like they they use that
sort of they take notes from Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball Z mmm-hmm like heavy and
then you see like name puns and Nardo
like the curatorial I was a huge fan of
the name puns
yeah right singing literally meant like
a vegetable yeah yeah Cheeta Kakarot
carrot obviously right radix radish yeah
right all I said to match those yeah
okay well we're gonna wrap this up where
can we find you guys on social media you
can find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
or Instagram at a truce hey Malcolm you
can find me at Malcolm DeRay on
twitter.com if I'm an twitter.com as
well this is a flash awesome underscore
Walter yeah follow me on there yes okay
so until next week these guys are great
power up with us guys you see the next
[Applause]